bonjour à tous bienvenue salaire de
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec catherine d'ailleurs
mojo katia toujours nickel et dans
l'actualité cette semaine un geste pour
les bas revenus 650 mille ménages
modestes vont sortir de l'impôt sur le
revenu annonce faite en début de semaine
et puis revu à la hausse en fin de
semaine par manuel valls seront
finalement 1 28 million de foyers qui
seront concernés un acte politique au
service d'un geste stratégique dit le
premier ministre et l'actualité
politique c'est aussi la réforme
territoriale françois hollande à engager
les consultations mais le sujet divise
l'opposition réclamait un référendum en
iran bourbonne voir notamment comment la
fusion envisagée et des régions est
accueilli et puis l'écotaxe désormais
rebaptisé éco redevance poids lourds la
mission parlementaire a fait treize
propositions pour aménager le dispositif
des propositions qui ne satisfont pas
vraiment la ministre de l'ecologie
ségolène royal qui l'a fait savoir
et avec nos jean marie le guen bonjour
j'ai beaucoup d'être sur le plateau de
parlement hebdo êtes secrétaire d'état
aux relations avec le parlement et
ancien député alors l'actualité
politique et parlementaire est très
chargé on va en parler tout de suite
mais d'abord je vous propose d'écouter
ce que pensent de vous certains de vos
anciens collègues
pour vous c'est
c'est vintage donc c'est la politique à
l'ancienne des gens qui savent ce que
c'est que la politique les rapports de
force voilà on aime ou on n'aime pas le
personnage mais c'est un vrai
professionnel qui sait faire son boulot
en général courtois c'est un député
expérimentés qui donc est
particulièrement
sa place comme
secrétaire d'état aux relations
avec des parlements socialiste bien
entendu mais surtout réformiste depuis
très longtemps et donc qu'il soit
aujourd'hui à la position d'organiser la
façon dont nous faisons ici le travail
au parlement pour réformer c'est
véritablement je trouve un bel atout en
ce moment son prédécesseur nos des
informations qui étaient fausses ruines
de pas d'information du tout alors
peut-être que c'est mieux que des
informations fausses ou enfin ce que
j'attends surtout lui c'est que et nous
informent ici du calendrier
parlementaire est qu'on puisse y avoir
un vrai échange un jean marie le guen
mais parlementaire serait mal informés
du calendrier parlementaire qu'est ce
que vous pouvez nous dire de ce
calendrier
via l'écouté j'ai eu l'occasion
d'informer la conférence des présidents
et donc par exemple le président du
groupe ump donc les informations ont été
données nous savons qui aura déjà un
certain nombre de textes de lois sur
tout le mois de juin j'ai annoncé l'idée
de la réforme pénale début juin nous
aurons évidemment les deux projets de
loi budgétaire sur la sécurité sociale
l'autre
ferroviaire bref tout ça est déjà engagé
et alors les territoires s'agissant du
sénat cette fois ci puisque il y aura
effectivement la réforme territoriale au
moins de juillet
et le parlement aura aussi à débattre de
cette liturgie j'espère vite vite vite
c'est ça parce qu'il faut aller vite oui
une procédure accélérée ça veut dire
quoi c'est quoi l'esprit de cette
procédure accélérée finalement alors la
procédure accélérée elle permet
manuellement bien il ya un temps trop
long aujourd'hui entre
le verbe politique et l'action politique
et surtout les résultats donc nous avons
et c'est un des principes de l'action de
manuel valls c'est d'essayer de
d'aller plus vite tout en garantissant
au parlement les droits de débats
auxquels il est logiquement attachés et
j'allais dire singulièrement la majorité
parlementaire donc nous avons décidé de
tweed aller vite parce que les français
parce que la situation nous demande
d'aller vite on va pas vite pour aller
vite on va vite parce qu'il ya besoin de
réformer ce pays mais ça veut dire que
ça fait beaucoup de texte tout ce que
vous nous citer l'aï les parlementaires
vont siéger jusqu'à quand tout et je
pense que les parlementaires devraient
j'ai à peu près la récession
extraordinaire jusqu'au 23 juillet c'est
une date qui est avancé je viens deux
petites secondes sur ce souhait c'est de
les libérer parce que une année il ya
une année chargée il ya une année très
chargée il faut être tout à fait à l
écoute de ceux qui nous disent de ce
point de vue je reviens sur ce qui été
dit un petit peu dans ce qu'on entend
sur les parlementaires vous n'avez pas
été tendre dans vos débuts c'est vrai
que c'était assez dur sur ce pacte de
responsabilité qu'il a fallu voter à un
peu à marche forcée vous avez pété assez
affligeant draps des choses qui sont
tout à fait fausses
ce qui est vrai c'est que en tant que
chargé des relations avec le parlement
j'ai eu une démarche assez pro actif
parce que j'ai trouvé d'ailleurs un
groupe majoritaire pour dire les choses
comme elles sont qui était assez
désorienté d'une part et puis avec un
sentiment aussi d'avoir pas été bien
traité par les membres du gouvernement
précédemment donc j'ai pris beaucoup de
contacts mais moi je suis dans le
respect des parlementaires je parle
politique un sens d'autres l'ont dit
donc j'ai des convictions j'ai des
argumentations je ne suis pas dans
l'esquivé je ne serai pas
le vrai oui mais je parle vrai au sens
où je respecte les gens parce que je
parle vrai quand on est dans l'esquivé
quand on est dans le non-dit ou quand on
est dans la fosse acquiescement si vous
voulez on respecte pas les gens moi je
respecte les parlementaires je sais je
suis un parlementaire expérimenté ça a
été dit et donc je sais qu'on doit les
traiter bien un jean marie le guen lundi
on parle de fiscalité
les impôts nouveau cheval de bataille du
gouvernement manuel valls annonce ce
premier chiffre en début de semaine six
cent cinquante mille ménages qui
seraient exemptés de l'impôt sur le
revenu à l'assemblée la mesure fait
réagir et à la réunion du groupe
socialiste mardi 22 membres du
gouvernement ont accompagné le premier
ministre à cette occasion et puis
quelques jours seulement après cette
première annonce suite des mesures
fiscales enfin c'est de manuel valls en
fin de semaine et il va beaucoup plus
loin puisque ça va toucher presque un
million pas dû lui foyer on va écouter
le premier quart d'heure débat juste
après la mesure que nous allons prendre
permettra à 1,8 million de ménages de
sortir de l'impôt sur un million huit
plus être soumis un as nous avons pensé
qu'il fallait une mesure encore plus
forte pour montrer aux français notre
engagement il faut sortir de cette
logique de l'impôt qui empêche qui
entraves qui empêchent les ménages de
consommer et qui en paie bien notre
économie de retrouver la compétitivité
comment on peut passer de 650 milles
dimanche soir à près de 2 millions le
vendredi matin
magique non c'est un ciblage différents
et c'est une réflexion à la fois
économique et social
économique parce que nous pensons que au
delà des mesures justes qui ont été
adoptées à savoir le fameux plan de 50
milliards d'euros d'économies de la
dépense publique il y à la nécessité en
même temps d'avoir un réglage fin de ce
qui est l'activité économique est en
l'occurrence l'un des moteurs de
l'activité économique la consommation et
puis deuxièmement nous avons constaté
dans les travaux qui ont été d'ailleurs
y compris menées par des parlementaires
sur le fait qu'un certain nombre de
mesures fiscales ont été chacune disons
les choses plutôt mal calibré et qui ont
fait qu'un servant de dispositifs qui
avaient été adoptées notamment par la
majorité précédente
la fameuse par des veuves le fait qu'on
n'avait par base est là ou là mais qui
quoi comment eh bien tous ces mesures
aboutissait à une le fait que des gens
qui n'avaient pas vu leurs revenus
augmenter se retrouvaient fiscalisés
donc ces gens là nous avons décidé d' à
vous de prendre une mesure et ça fait
partie des 1 million 8 c'est un peu plus
d'un million et plus importants y avait
en gros huit cent mille personnes qui
allaient être fiscalisés alors qu'ils ne
l'étaient pas dû nous allons avec la
mesure qui est pris c'est à dire une
mesure qui consiste à donner un crédit
d'impôt
oui un crédit d'impôt de 3 dans une
réduction d'impôt pardon de 350 euros
pour une personne est de 700 euros pour
un couple avec ça il ya 1,8 million de
personnes qui étaient fiscalisés qui ne
le seront plus ça fait beaucoup d'argent
tout ça et ça fait 3 excusez moi juste 1
et 3 vous allez on a le temps de revenir
sur les toutes les questions que vous me
posez mais il ya aussi trois millions de
français trois millions de français de
ménages qui seront touchés par cette
mesure juste c'est à dire qui si je peux
dire avant et ça peut intéresser vos
auditeurs c'est tout les françaises un
célibataire qui gagne 14 mille euros en
gros le smic sera impacté par cette
mesure un couple avec trois enfants
38000 euros tous ces gens là alors après
il ya les coupes avec deux enfants je
vais pas vous donner toute la grille
mais tous ces gens là trente-huit mille
euros c'est quand même un revenu déjà
deux couches moyennes dans notre pays
pour une famille avec trois enfants ces
gens là verront leurs impôts baisser et
une partie d'entre eux sortiront de
toute fiscalité 1 million à 3 millions
touché ça a été annoncé par le premier
ministre un coup c'est un milliard
d'euros comment comment aller vu parce
que nous avons vu que nous avons des
marges de progression dans la lutte sur
la fraude fiscale
nous pouvons les cheveux roses fiscale
elle vient du fait que un certain nombre
de dispositifs ont été adoptés qui
permettent de renforcer l'action de
l'état pour éviter sur la tva sur un
salon dessus d'avoir de meilleures
rentrées moins de fraudes d'une part
deuxièmement vous savez aussi qu'il ya
un certain nombre de gens qui s'étaient
expatriés et qui donc sans compter
d'aujourd'hui c'est une cagnotte vous
savez le terme cagnotte en général il a
il a abouti à des non sens économique
mais en tout théâtre cause ya des marges
de manoeuvre il ya une volonté politique
de justice sociale une volonté politique
de bons réglages de les connaître la
culture du sac à linge est très fort qui
a été la question c'est la fin de la
rigueur des efforts demandés à tous non
je ne crois pas à l'effort et demandé il
ya un certain nombre de nos compatriotes
qui verront leurs impôts qui vont
augmenter parce qu'ils ont des revenus
qui ont augmenté donc il y a toujours la
justice il y aller fort simplement
lorsque ça repose sur les plus fragiles
et les plus pauvres des classes moyennes
nous agissons je rappelle que l'impôt
soit touchée elle reste touché la classe
moyenne oui mais c'est quoi les classes
moyennes c'est
vrai le privé en l'occurrence non là
quand on est à 38 mille euros de revenus
annuels pour trois enfants on est
clairement dans les classes moyennes
donc une fraction importante je dis pas
la totalité des classes moyennes mais
une fraction importante des classes
moyennes au verront leurs impôts des ces
ruptures ou pas du quinquennat ce n'est
pas une rupture c'est une évolution une
accélération vers la réforme juste
voulait toute l'action du gouvernement
sera au tour de l' équilibre entre ces
deux mots la réforme et la justice c'est
ça le principe dans lequel régime créé
nous avons 2 le premier ministre a eu
des mots forts ça a été soulignée
notamment par vous même sur la fiscalité
lorsqu'il est intervenu en disant trop
de fiscalité tu la pause lorsque les
avais dit lorsqu'il a déclaré qu'il
avait bien conscience que le niveau de
fiscalité avait atteint dans notre pays
des niveaux insupportables attendu
municipal non c'est pas simplement le
message des municipales c'est aussi
l'étude réel de ce qui se passe de ce
que nous il est français mais c'est
aussi le message des municipales bien
sûr que c'est aussi le message des
municipales élections européennes non
parce que les annonces qui sont faites
aujourd'hui n'ont rien à voir avec le
calendrier quoi que vous puissiez le
ça tombe bien mais ce n'est pas
lié à ces élections mais vous savez je
ne crois pas que les français pour pré
sincèrement les françaises qui veulent
savoir c'est ce qui va se passer au mois
de septembre sur leur feuille de paie et
pour ils ne votent pas comme des
automates ya pas d homme politique qui
vient de leur donner trois souhaits hop
je vote pour eux je retire trois souches
de vote plus pour eux ça moi quand je
parle à des citoyens en tout cas dans ma
circonscription
j'ai en face de moi des femmes et des
hommes qui pensent à l'avenir de leur
pays à l'avenir de leurs enfants et ils
sont ils sont pas des automates dans
lequel un comme un flipper on met un
euro puissent époux y sont contents non
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche alors
jean marie le guen certains sont très
inquiets les militaires on va parler des
inquiétudes qui pèsent sur le budget de
la défense c'est mardi
le gouvernement doit trouver 4 milliards
d'euros pour le collectif budgétaire
d'ici le mois de juin et l'opposition
craint des coupes sévères sur le budget
de la défense une question soulevée par
le député xavier bertrand échanges dans
l'hémicycle lors des questions
d'actualité avec le ministre des
finances écouter dimanche matin j'ai
accusé le président de la république et
votre gouvernement de préparer un
nouveau plan de réduction des dépenses
militaires le ministère de l'économie a
bien confirmé c'est aujourd'hui dans le
journal les échos qu'un tel plan est à
l'étude un tel plan qui verrait des
réductions des coûts budgétaires d'un
milliard et demi à deux milliards
d'euros par an dans un délai compris
entre 3 ans et 5 ans vous nous parler
d'une diminution de 2 milliards par an
pendant trois ans voire même cinq ans si
je fais un bon calcul ça veut dire aux
alentours de 6 milliards de moins pour
les crédits de la défense par rapport à
30 milliards le budget d'aujourd'hui une
diminution de 20% il n'en est pas
question monsieur bertrand vous en plus
vous employez des chiffres qui n'ont
rien à voir notre programmation
militaire telle qu'elle a été votée 35
milliards sur cinq ans vous y toucher ou
pas non nous n'y toucherons pas ces
polémiques sont à la fois peu ridicule
et on entendait michel sapin faire la
démonstration que les propos
extravagant
de l'ump n'avait pas de sens et xavier
bertrand en l'occurrence bien maintenant
je suis nul parce qu'il a acquise avec
bertrand qu'est ce qui vous permet bien
que s'acheva sur la guitare aussi qui
ont fait remonter l'information mais
peut-être que les militaires disent des
choses qui sont inexactes et monsieur
xavier bertrand a peut-être envie de
raconter des choses qui sont inexactes a
dit que ça pourrait être pas mal aussi
de voir les chiffres qui ont été données
par xavier bertrand sont extravagants
bien maintenant est ce que est ce que on
regarde le budget de la défense comme
les autres budgets évidemment en ayant
le souci de respecter à la fois la loi
de programmation militaire et toutes les
problématiques de souveraineté
maintenant j'aimerais savoir une fois
pour toutes comment l'ump qui prétend
faire 130 milliards d'économies qu'il
nous dise où et comment elle fait ses
économies c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
d'un côté avoir une fois par mois des
discours de l'ump qui nous disent vous
n'en fait pas assez et toutes les
semaines des interventions des
parlementaires qui nous disent vous en
faites trop s'il ya un moment où ces
postures politiques n'ont plus aucun
sens et ils affaiblissent la crédibilité
de la parole politique mais si on
comprend bien là le gouvernement ne va
pas demander d'efforts supplémentaires
aux armées qui ont déjà consenti le
gouvernement fit jusqu'à déjà demandé
des efforts alors mais
il y aura des efforts qui seront
demandés de façon continue à l'ensemble
de ses acteurs en ayant le souci d'avoir
la sauvegarde des principes fondamentaux
et des engagements qui ont été pris par
le président de la république
gêné si vous voulez bien avec sur le
terrain de la réforme des territoires
katia avec une nouvelle carte de france
à l'horizon la réforme territoriale doit
être précisée à la fin du mois de mai en
conseil des ministres le président a
consulté les différentes formations
politiques pour compter ses soutiens
l'opposition elle réclame un référendum
sur ce sujet qui divise l amont d'un
gars va
françois hollande réussira-t-il à
dégager un consensus autour de la
réforme territoriale
si l'idée de simplifier les
collectivités met tout le monde d'accord
simplifier le millefeuille et et faire
en sorte qu'il soit plus efficace et
moins coûteux il faut sortir de ce
millefeuille territorial qui est
auquel plus personne ne comprend rien je
plaide pour depuis des années pour qu'on
en finisse du millefeuille territorial
à droite on s'accorde sur les critiques
contre le gouvernement
manoeuvre pour décaler les élections et
retour du conseiller territorial
supprimé par la gauche l'ump est aussi
unie sur l'idée d'un référendum les
français diront ce qu'ils en pensent
parce que il n'est pas acceptable que
l'on vienne bouleverser pour des
questions personnelles d'intérêts
politiciens
l'équilibré de notre pays sans débat
avec personne mais si certains sont pour
une réduction du nombre de régions
d'autres s'y opposent je suis contre le
regroupement des régions pour sauf à la
marge il ya des régions qui peuvent être
regroupées petit nom pourquoi parce que
j'ai pas du tout envie d'avoir demain 8
ou 10 barons régionaux qui n'auront de
cesse que d'empêcher la mise en oeuvre
des réformes que l'état doit conduire le
centre favorable à la suppression d'un
échelon territorial des noms celui des
imprécisions du gouvernement on nous dit
qu'on va regrouper des grandes régions
sans même nous dire quelles vont être
les compétences les moyens les budgets
bref on avance vers manifestement sous
le coup des annonces médiatiques mais
pas d'une réflexion alors que chez les
verts on encourage une réforme nous
invitons le président de la république
et le premier ministre à ne pas avoir
peur si on a peur des conservatismes qui
vont s'exprimer c'est sûr et certain sur
la réforme territoriale et il va y avoir
tout un tas de prétextes pour ne rien
faire mais françois hollande aura
également à convaincre son propre camp
sur le terrain des élus socialistes
pourraient se montrer très réticent à
l'idée de voir leurs responsabilités
remise en cause alors on s'arrête
justement sur cette réforme c'est le
zoom de la semaine
on accueille julie benetti
bonjourbonjour cet agrégé des facultés
de droit professeur à l'université de
reims champagne ardenne alors on va
parler de cette réforme avec jean marie
le guen d'abord votre votre point de vue
il semble que la piste du référendum sur
cette réforme de va pas être suivi quels
sont aujourd'hui les options du
président de la république pour la faire
passer référendum congrès où rien de
cela il semble que la piste d'une
révision constitutionnelle était écarté
hier dans ces conditions
l'alternative entre la tenue d'un
référendum où la réunion du congrès ne
se pose plus tout dépend de ce que veut
faire le gouvernement s'agissant des
options juridiques si comme l'ambition
initiale du gouvernement le laisser
penser il s'agit de supprimer les
départements il faut une révision de la
constitution pour cette raison très
simple que la constitution protège à son
article 72 l'existence du département
qui fait partie des collectivités
territoriales de la république donc si
l'on veut supprimer le département l'on
doit réviser la constitution
de la même façon une simple loi une loi
ordinaire ne peut pas même en maintenant
la catégorie départementale la vider de
sa substance et prévoir soit la
suppression des conseils départementaux
soit le transfert des compétences
départementales aux intercommunalités ou
aux régions pour une raison très simple
là encore c'est que le principe de libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales qui est un principe
constitutionnel implique d'une part une
assemblée lui ce qui a pour effet de
protéger les conseils départementaux et
d'autre part des attributions effective
ce client steam ce qui interdit tout
transfert significative les compétences
départementales vers d'autres niveaux
d'administration jean marie le guen vous
avez dit que la piste de la révision
constitutionnelle ne serait pas suivi
non je n'ai pas exactement bien je ne
sais pas la piste que nous prenions je
veux dire par là que
ici dans la discussion parlementaire il
apparaît tu sais que nous ne
subordonnons pas notre action de réforme
à la réforme constitutionnelle
maintenant peut-être que dans le cadre
des discussions avec les parlementaires
il y aura l'apparition d'un élément qui
met en avant la nécessité d'avoir une
évolution constitutionnelle sur tel ou
tel point moi je ne ferme pas la
discussion parlementaire mais le
gouvernement ne subordonnent pas le
projet de loi les orientations qui sont
les siennes à une réforme
constitutionnelle
quel est le calendrier pour cette île et
match lille et d'aller devant le sénat
dès cette cession ou la session
extraordinaire du mois de juillet avant
l'été en tout cas la suppression du
conseiller départemental
est ce que c'est le fameux big bang
territorial est ce que
constitutionnellement c'est valable tout
cela est ce qu'on va pouvoir regarder ça
de très près aussi la suppression des
conseils départementaux implique une
révision de la constitution en tout état
de cause là dessus je crois qu'il n'y a
pas de débat a duré bien docile jour ou
de révision de la constitution cela
implique d'une part qu'il y ait un
accord entre les deux assemblées du
parlement avant même la soumission du
projet au référendum au congrès il faut
d'abord un accord entre les deux
assemblées du parlement et donc cela
implique que le gouvernement puisse
trouver une majorité au sénat puisque en
matière constitutionnelle le veto du
sénat est insurmontable et à supposer
que le projet soit adopté par les deux
assemblées en termes identiques alors la
question se poserait de savoir si le
plan de la république choisirait
l'organisation d'un référendum où la
réunion du bureau adressent au
secrétaire d'état parce que c'est
important au sénat visiblement le groupe
socialiste a pas l'air au mans très
enclin à vous aider là dessus
non il est il et il réfléchit je pense
qu'il ya vous savez il ya une prise de
conscience de ce qui est possible
pourquoi on fait ça on fait ça parce que
tout simplement nous a person que
l'organisation territoriale ne
correspond plus aux besoins de
compétitivité de solidarité exprimée par
nos compatriotes
les métropoles ne fonctionne pas bien et
on ne voit pas pourquoi il ya dans une
métropole les départements directement
des conseils généraux et des des
collectivités de communes et puis dans
les territoires ruraux on nous parle
souvent de la difficulté la
désertification rurale du malaise du
monde rural et on s'aperçoit que
finalement la carte administrative ne
correspond plus haut à la réalité du
pays à la réalité de la vie aux
compétitions économique à la solidarité
qui devrait exister donc c'est pour ça
que nous réformons c'est pour ça que
nous réformons et c'est donc nous allons
avancer de façon à faire qui est plus de
proximité et plus de force le conseiller
départemental ça suffit non c'est à dire
la réforme sera beaucoup plus globale et
on parle je vais pas vous en reparler en
15 secondes parce que ce serait juste
ridicule mais on va faire des régions
beaucoup plus forte wen lors de l'arrêt
activités économiques on va avoir une
action de l'état beaucoup plus fort sur
les territoires on va avoir des
collectivités territoriales qui vont
être renforcées dans tout ce qui est la
problématique de l'intercommunalité de
façon à ce que véritablement il y ait à
la fois et de la proximité et les
services publics proches notamment dans
les zones fragilisées qui soit
véritablement opérationnel et nous
allons faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
par principe quatre niveaux d'échelon
qui crée de la confusion des texans vrai
j'aimerais le guen les textes sont en
train d'être travaillés sont en train
d'être finalisé et sincère demandé
pardon à quoi ça sert de recevoir les
partis politiques allez disons à ceux il
ya selon de choses sur lesquelles il ya
des consensus par exemple sur les
compétences alors vous parlez dont
parlaient les consensus des éléments de
consensus les compétences de nez aux
régions une grande partie du texte qui a
déjà été avancée par marylise lebranchu
me semble-t-il correspondent très
largement à ce que souhaitent les un
réseau et les parties sont par essence
sont claires aujourd'hui ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de compétences qui sont non
plus
vous avez raison c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que nous reviendrons sur la clause de
comptes dite de compétence générale sauf
pour le sport et pour la culture parce
que là il ya effectivement
traditionnellement la nécessité d'avoir
plusieurs éléments vous restez avec nous
des petites secondes on va s'intéresser
donc aux régions la réforme territoriale
qui touchera les régions parce qu'on va
donc certainement les supprimer en tout
cas par deux le nombre de régions deux
régions ont déjà proposé de fusionner de
se marier alors on va voir comment ça se
passe ça se passe en bourgogne et en
franche-comté reportage faustine sa
jeunesse
c'est le mariage dont tout le monde
parle celui de la bourgogne avec la
franche comté les deux régions pourrait
fusionner comme le souhaitent leurs deux
président marie-guite dufay il françois
patriat hier matin à dijon première
session au conseil régional depuis
l'annoncé de la probable fusion le
président martel son objectif supprimer
les doublons
enfin c'est mieux
s'il n'existe pas encore d'études
françois patriat a déjà ses estimations
avec rapprochement proximale on peut
déjà tabler sur environ 10 millions
d'euros d'économies dix millions c'est
beaucoup en fonctionnement et si demain
nos universités fusionnent ce que
j'espère depuis six ans et que nous
n'avons plus de formations redondantes
et que nous avons de bonnes formations
dans chacune des régions vous fera des
économies loeb qui sont pas chiffrés
m'entendent est évidente autre piste un
seul aéroport au lieu de deux ou encore
des achats groupés pour obtenir des
rabais une décision qui semble bien
accueillie par les habitants des deux
régions quand même j'ai roulé deux
régions
des sous-ministres enfin
niche très favorable si la région est
plus grande avec les moyens de
communication c'est pas ça qui me fait
peur garder son identité ça c'est
quelque chose qui est possible le qu'il
restera le cuir la cancoillotte restera
là tant qu'on y est effectivement ça
pourrait supprimer des doublons au
niveau administratif
mais il faut que le service public de
proximité reste de proximité beaucoup de
questions restent en suspens comme le
nom de la future capitale de la région
certains redoute un déclassement de
besançon plusieurs collectifs franc
comtois rejette farouchement cette
fusion potentielle comme le mouvement
sauvons la franche comté il dénonce un
mariage forcé la franche comté a besoin
d'une autonomie accrue alors que nous
vivons ce projet de fusion au contraire
comme un retour en arrière et c'est un
axe qui est développé par deux personnes
qui sont super tri yann même du fait
qu'ils ne prennent pas en compte les
revendications et c'est leur bébé nous
on n'en serait pas on nous a rien
demandé elle pire ce sont des gens qui
se vantent aujourd'hui de ne pas
convoquer un référendum c'est quand même
grave en démocratie un point de vue
partagé par certains élus qui réclament
eux aussi un référendum
inc est choquant même qui découlent de
tout cela ce sont la date des élections
régionales les deux auront lieu en
bien écoutez si le projet de loi est
adopté ce que je crois elles sont
repoussé de plusieurs mois au pire une
année est-ce que c'est constitutionnel
de toucher à la date des élections il ya
deux conditions
auxquelles
la date des élections qu être reporté
contre les pales conseil constitutionnel
première condition il faut que ce report
répondent à un intérêt général seconde
condition il faut que les électeurs
soient appelés à se prononcer selon une
périodicité
raisonnable je pense que cj sens du
report de la date des élections
régionales ça ne devrait pas poser de
difficultés c'est un peu plus gênant
s'agissant des élections départementales
dans la mesure où ces élections la dette
de ces les élections a déjà été reportée
d'un an elle pourrait donc être reporté
de deux ans et dans ces conditions le
conseil qu'en semaine elle pourrait être
amenée à apprécier si la gale à une
périodicité raisonnable votre réponse
sur
ce constat moi je n'ai pas de crainte
particulière mais c'est normal que le
conseil constitutionnel se penche sur
l'ensemble des lois qui sont adoptées
c'est une garantie pour vous écouter
certains risques oui en même temps c'est
une réalité donc tous là prenant en
compte merci beaucoup je dis bénéfice
pour ses éclairages et mercredi et jean
marie le guen l'écotaxe refait parler
d'elle
et court devant ce poids lourd se serait
le nouveau nom de l'écotaxe la mission
parlementaire qui a travaillé sur le
sujet a remis son rapport elle propose
de maintenir cet effort axe mais en
l'aménageant la contribution verte qui a
mis le feu aux poudres à la bretagne il
y a 6 mois on en parle avec jérémy
hartmann
à l'automne dernier les bonnets rouges
avaient obtenu son scalp depuis
l'écotaxe est retombée dans l'oubli sauf
pour une cinquantaine de députés chargés
de trouver des aménagements à ce
dispositif très controversé première
proposition remplacer l'appellation
d'écotaxe par celle des coraux devant ce
poids lourd car il s'agit d'un péage
plus que d'une taxe l'écotaxe n'est pas
un impôt qui serait la marque d'une
écologie punitive c'est une redevance à
payer par les utilisateurs des routes
jusqu'ici vous le savez les empreintes
gratuitement sur le fond le rapport
prévoit une franchise kilométrique les
transporteurs routiers dont les camions
parcs auront moins de 400 kilomètres par
mois
on pas à payer une façon de protéger les
acteurs de proximité et cibler davantage
le transport international autre mesure
envisagée faire fonctionner le système à
blanc jusqu'à la fin de l'année pour
tester son bon fonctionnement
et voir s'il est accepté par tous mais
malgré toutes ces modifications
le rapport ne fait toujours pas
l'unanimité parmi les membres de la
mission parlementaire 18 députés ont
voté pour 14 contre on veut appliquer
les pros taxe à tout prix des
améliorations qui sont du cosmétique qui
sont dus ripolinage qui sont pas autre
chose ça ne fait pas illusion un quart
de seconde ce sera vécue je le crains
comme une véritable provocation
au moins dans la région dans le suis
issu en bretagne scepticisme y compris
au sein du gouvernement ségolène royal
la ministre de l'ecologie en charge du
dossier ne semblent pas convaincus par
les conclusions du rapport faut qu'on
trouve des solutions simples mais qui
n'augmente pas la pression fiscale sur
des entreprises de production oui les
artisans les commerçants les
agriculteurs ceux qui ont besoin du
transport par camion ils peuvent pas
payer les impôts supplémentaires
donc s'il ya d'autres solutions il faut
les privilégiés le flou reste donc
entier sur l'avenir de cet éco redevance
poids lourds la ministre de l'ecologie
promet des arbitrages d'ici juin alors
arbitrage d'ici juin mais dans quel sens
j'en aie le guen parce que la ministre
l'écologie n'a pas le même avis que le
président de la gestion enfin eu lieu je
ne peux pas vous les donnez vous
comprenez bien simplement cette affaire
de l'écotaxe elle est mal parti cette
histoire depuis le début voilà un des
conditions d'un contrat public privé
tout ça tout ça est compliqué mais
revenir à son maintien revenir en
arrière et extrêmement difficile aussi
parce qu'une bonne partie des éléments
fondamentaux des infrastructures de
notre pays est liée aux produits de
cette écotaxe donc nous sommes pris dans
dans une situation très compliquée et si
elle avait été mieux fait au point de
départ on serait dans une situation
moins moins complexe et d'ailleurs je
trouve un peu
sur le fur qui est celui qui a voté
l'écotaxe avec ses collègues de l'ump
venir faire des leçons maintenant je
trouve que ça manque un petit peu de
bonne foi
sur bien plus loin il faut trouver des
compromis lyon va trouver des compromis
mais moi j'ai tout à fait confiance
je pense qu une partie d une grande
partie des propositions qui sont celles
de la mission sont très intéressantes
ségolène royal va apporter aussi sa
propre vision des choses non mais je ne
crois pas qu'ils ratifient ségolène veut
mettre à contribution les autoroutes est
ce que c'est la bonne voie pour vous
c'est une bonne façon de parler sur les
voies des autoroutes je pense que
quelque part d'ailleurs le président de
la commission je l'espère chanteguet est
allé aussi dans ce sens il veut regarder
il ya évidemment là aussi il ya eu que
vous savez une privatisation
des autoroutes où il ya une manne pour
un certain nombre d'entreprises qui pose
problème aux finances publiques et
j'allais dire aux finances publiques
donc il est logique de regarder tout ça
avec 5 commence à faire peur à pas le
mot taxe oui les il fait peur je pense
que si vous voulez de se rapprocher
d'ailleurs de cette vision bon on a
confondu en plus deux choses déjà les
taxes et pas trop mais là il y avait ce
qu'on pouvait appeler ce qu'on appelle
en économie ou textes comportementale et
puis une taxe de revenus sert qu'on
avait besoin de revenus d'un côté mais
de l'autre côté on voulait faire évoluer
la taxe la taxe conformant
comportementale est la vocation à aller
tout doucement et à dire voilà dans
trois ans dans cinq ans dans dix ans ça
va coûter de plus en plus cher donc ayez
un autre comportement bon et puis la
taxe de revenus c'est j'ai besoin
d'argent
pour vous êtes vous utilisez les
autoroutes bon et bien
moi j'ai besoin d'argent pour faire des
oraux des routes et des autos pour et
donc je vous prends l'argent ça a été
mélangé la danse dans ce projet tout ça
est assez mal fichu donc le problème
maintenant de la déconstruction
reconstruction est un peu compliqué et
c'est pas lieu pas un moment de
polémiques s'invente travail plus 100%
de son temps sur ce dossier y aura pas
de nouvelles taxes d'écotaxe tout de
suite non et le vocabulaire
effectivement n'est pas déjà une bonne
chose mais enfin si vous voulez faire
des tgv faire un certain nombre
d'aménagements tout à fait fondamentaux
pour notre pays pour avoir une mobilité
plus durable moins énergivores ce après
suppose des investissements
investissementsa présuppose de l'argent
et l'argent faut donc aller le trouver
et donc pour ça et bien il faut bien
qu'on opère des transferts un ya pas de
mystère et tout le reste c'est du pipeau
qu'on raconte aux français il faut bien
trouver de l'argent pour financer ce
dont on a besoin de moi je restais sur
les bons mots de katia ce que vous ne
seriez pas d'épreuve de poids lourds
dans votre gouvernement notamment avec
ségolène royal elle a eu des quelques
propos ont été retranscrits dans le
magazine paris match ça quand même créé
la polémique même si elle est un petit
peu revenu en arrière on va voir ça avec
thibault le floch
ségolène royal se plaint du procès en
incompétence dont elle s'estime victime
au sein même du gouvernement elle évoque
des boules puantes la condescendance et
le mépris de certains ministres à son
égard sans les nommer une attitude
qu'elle met sur le dos d'une classe
politique majoritairement composés de
macho sûrs de leur bon droit pourtant
celle qui a été nommée ministre de
l'écologie il y à un mois et demi estime
avoir largement mérité sa place au
gouvernement
je fais mon travail et le reste je m'en
fiche je suis à ce poste parce que je
suis compétente peut être même la plus
compétente ainsi ségolène royal n'hésite
pas à donner son avis sur le dossier
alstom alors que son collègue arnaud
montebourg est favorable à un rachat par
l'allemand siemens la ministre de
l'ecologie plaide pour l'américain
general electric
c'est une très bonne opportunité pour
alstom c'est le meilleur projet
industriel pourquoi ne pas le dire
puis elle tacle violemment la manière de
faire du min trop du redressement
productif pourquoi vouloir
systématiquement faire fuir les
investisseurs étrangers nous en avons
bien besoin pourtant conséquent ce matin
impossible pour stéphane le foll porte
parole du gouvernement d'échapper aux
questions des journalistes sur
l'affrontement royal montebourg autour
du dossier alsthom moi je ne ferai pas
de commentaires supplémentaires sur ce
sujet mais je le rappelle la réussite
de chacun des ministres c'est d'abord la
réussite collective du gouvernement
quelques minutes plus tard sur le perron
de l'elysée ségolène royal qui devait
s'exprimer sur l'écotaxe revient sur ses
propos rapportés dans paris match
travaillant collectivement donc je ne
laisse pas déstabiliser par des petites
phrases de dans la presse qui sont
toujours amusants certains journalistes
aucune faille dans la solidarité
gouvernementale selon la ministre mais
déjà certains députés socialistes y voit
le premier couac du gouvernement de
manuel valls bon alors est fréquent
réunion avec les ministres secrétaires
d'état manuel valls un petit peu recadré
tout le monde aux stèles je dis ça aussi
une façon générale manuel valls nous
nous appelle à travailler de façon
collective et il a raison je pense que
chacun comprend bien qui a pas de
réussite individuelle lignac de réussite
collective et c'est en semences si tout
particulièrement voilà a pas de cas
particulier dans le gouvernement il n'y
a pas d'exception non il n'y a pas
d'exception il ya un travail collectif
il ya une volonté de travailler
collectivement avec la majorité on
demande d'ailleurs à la majorité d'être
plus collective plus rassembler et donc
c'est un principe majeur c'est pas de
quoi donner quand même le bon exemple
pour les parlementaires aussi ce qu'on
entend pour ça que nous sommes très
vigilants a demandé que tout se passe
dans une dans un état d'esprit
d'ailleurs qui existent par ailleurs je
pense qu'il ya eu des phrases rapporté
démenti d'ailleurs donc moi je ne vais
pas m'exprimer là-dessus mais je peux
témoigner très sincèrement et très
simplement du fait que l'état d'esprit
positif à l'intérieur il n'y a pas
d'éléments incontrôlables de place à
part tout le monde entend ce message je
ne vois pas comment il pourrait y avoir
des éléments incontrôlables alors on va
finir avec un peu de patriotisme c'est
très bien
un décret permet à l'état français de
s'opposer à la prise de contrôle d'une
entreprise française par des
investissements étrangers cinq nouveaux
secteurs stratégiques sont concernés
décret sur mesure pour alstom la réponse
avec mario lefebvre il a été rebaptisé
décret alstom signé hier par manuel
valls publié aujourd'hui au journal
officiel
il sera en vigueur dès demain ce décret
permet de protéger les entreprises
stratégiques des investissements
étrangers pour investir les entreprises
étrangères devront obtenir
l'autorisation préalable du gouvernement
pour entrer au capital des entreprises
françaises dans le domaine de l'énergie
des transports de l'eau de la santé et
des télécoms pour matignon l'état doit
avoir son mot à dire concernant les
investissements étrangers dans les
secteurs stratégiques
c'est vrai en france comme c'est vrai
que partout ailleurs pourquoi ce que
seule la france serait dépourvu de
capacité de peser non pas d'interdire
mais d'être dans le dialogue dans le
dialogue avec les grandes entreprises
internationales mais à partir il s'agit
de l'armement lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'énergie plan il s'agit de l'eau
lorsqu'il s'agit de secteurs qui sont
des secteurs mais il ya quelques temps
vous désirez aller quand il s'agit de
lieux de décision parce que c'est un
vrai sujet ou quand il s'agit de
questions d'emploi à l'état un mois
tiers s'est s'inquiété dit ni plus ni
moi n'y a pas de changement par rapport
à ce qu'a été la position depuis depuis
que cette question d'alstom a été posée
le décret élargit en fait à cinq
nouveaux secteurs le dispositif mis en
place en 2005 par dominique de villepin
pour les secteurs de la défense et de la
sécurité en réflexion depuis plusieurs
mois ce décret a été accéléré à la suite
des négociations de general electric
pour racheter les activités énergie
d'alstom c'est aussi un signal politique
assumée à quelques jours des élections
européennes
alors signal politique assumée à
quelques jours des européennes manoeuvre
politique
l'impression que ce décret est en
décalage avec la réalité économique
pas du tout je pense qu'il y à une
réalité économique qui était en décalage
avec la réalité des peuples c'est à dire
l'idée que tous ceux s'achète et tout se
vend sans que personne n'ait rien à y
dire est que la notion même de
collectivité nationale ne puisse pas
intervenir que l'état
soit simple le simple spectateur du
dépeçage des mouvements financiers cette
idée là est absente
non et c'est pour ça que c'est pas
simplement le problème un décret alstom
c'est un décret stratégique a été
programmé vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
depuis plusieurs mois et donc il
concerne bien au-delà du cas d'alstom il
concerne en l'occurrence air câlin
régime et qu'on pourrait regarder sans
rien dire le fait que les uns des
éléments essentiels des centrales
nucléaires construites par la france à
savoir les turbines à vapeur puissent
être vendus à l'encan à n'importe qui
enfin c'est pas assez parce que ça va
changer quelque chose dans l'accord en
tout cas dans leurs achats d'alstom par
un general electric ou par siemens
bonjour cause que en l'occurrence nous
avons regardé très près indépendamment
de l'ensemble du dossier la partie ce
noyau c'est j'ose dire qui et les
aspects énergie nucléaire et qu'ils ne
seront pas quoi qu'il arrive vendus à
l'encan ou soumis à des règles que nous
n'a que le gouvernement n'apprécierait
pas signal pour les entreprises
étrangères c'est quoi c'est la france
que je faisais dix ans la france se fait
exactement ce que font tous le monsieur
n'est pas du tout c'est nous mêmes on se
demande même comment on n'a pas fait ce
décret plutôt j'allais dire c'est plutôt
sale et on mériterait d'être interprété
l'interpellé là dessus et pas simplement
ce gouvernement mais les gouvernements
précédents à la commission européenne
tire-t-elle le métal en garde la france
pratique la constitution européenne vous
le savez sur une ligne d'un libre
échangisme c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
nous nous souhaitons aussi changer la
commission européenne parce que nous
avons eu notre rapport de la politique
économique pour le juste échange pour
une politique économique qui soit
véritablement une politique non pas
idéologique et libérale comme le fait
cette commission domine et par la droite
pour ça qu'en votant pour martin schulz
et en votant pour les listes socialistes
il y aura une autre une autre nom mais
c'est un véritable enjeu c'est un enjeu
démocratique est un enjeu majeur
l'europe on considère ça comme étant un
acquis ce n'est pas le cas notre paie
notre sécurité on le voit avec l'ukraine
en dépend et notre politique économique
industriel oc donc pas de
protectionnisme et du patriotisme quand
même exactement dix ans mercy quart
d'heure avec nous on se retrouve sur une
prochaine 14 le plaisir même s'il était
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires merci